hola a todos nosotros somos mi canoa
estamos presentando nuestro segundo
disco no hay mal que ver una vida 11
canciones hechas con puro amor hemos
tocado en festivales internacionales y
nacionales dándole 4 años constantemente
así que ahora nos damos con nuestro show
y espero que lo disfrute
bien
e
[Música]
sé que creer fue un error
lo que sucedió
todo lo cambio
no sé si alguien te lastimó
a mí me pasó
no creo en él
pero no
la vez que te veo siento que pierdo el
miedo a mí
y confiar de nuevo con mis manos al
fuego casa
ves que te veo siento que pierdo el
miedo
tus brazos me quedo con mis manos el
fuego
[Música]
a mí
cuando todo se derrumbó
el tiempo pasó
se llevó
[Música]
y aunque la cicatriz quedo
y arte en el interior
ya no
porque mi casa
la vez que te veo siento que pierde el
miedo
me confiar mejor con mis manos el fuego
es que te veo siento que pierdo el miedo
en sus pasos me quedo con mis manos y si
quemas mi corazón
no pidas perdón
fue mi decisión
[Música]
sí
escape en mi cuerpo por incendios y la
crisis que lento me fue consumiendo
creer
es el olvido es el remedio no
cree share
[Música]
bien
sí
y mis lienzos pintaste
con tus cenizas quien ostenta llamas mis
heridas de cáncer
son las ruinas del recuerdo que queme
[Música]
escape en mi cuerpo
un incendio si está triste lento me fue
consumiendo qué
me quisieron sido es el remedio no me
cree saber
[Música]
bien
a nuestros ojos son umbrales que revela
y nuestros males
es un fuego cubrir
tu piel de oro pero se desvanecen
las ciudades de papel
con los fantasmas del pasado que enterré
es saber en mi cuerpo
un incendio chica triste
de donde fue consumiendo t
me que cielo olvido es el remedio no
saleh
[Música]
la cicatriz
efe
[Música]
ah
no
[Música]
sí
no te quieres con las ganas de nada por
miedo a los demás no hay nadie más
de atrasados fantasmas tranquila quien
este lugar que pueda lastimar
quiero que sepas que es algo que nunca
cuida nuestra espalda
anuncia
a bailar mientras sus besos lo que va
actuar
cuando siguiente con temor
movimiento
todas
las tres de esos gigantes
creciendo
quiero que sepas que se alimenta de vida
es cantar
no lo sé
bailar mientras los besos
[Música]
qué bien
e
y
que sepas que si algo te atormenta cuida
tu espalda
y vamos a bailar mientras los vasos ue
sólo cubran tu alma
quieres más que sea algo que atenta
mirada de su espalda
vamos a bailar mientras nuevas esos
tantos
y
[Música]
no no